every single day I have to put up with
so much and abuse and mean comments from
you guys it's always like I'm the end of
the joke
I'm the always the part of their joke
not no no not today that's right I'm
going to roast you guys
I've been collecting comments secretly
for the past couple of weeks and then I
picked the ones that are make you guys
seeing the dumbest so now we're going to
read them as I litter all new gasps
Puetz you are so mature about everything
except when it comes to pop geom
fortnight seriously cut that childish
hate fortnight because I play pub G act
and act rationally think about it you
hate this game because it said it's a
copy of pub G but in reality it's not
for neither expect to it we just think
we're pathetic
this is bad basically all my comments
there's a bunch of kids here all lowlife
losers you know that right
have you ever seen a bug onna I don't
think so it's not the wise you wouldn't
argue about fortnight and why is better
than pub G you pathetic losers what are
you gonna do dislike the video is that
what you're gonna do
please don't please don't think I'm
joking I'm joking we're just having fun
here guys come on
all right come on we got to have a
little bit hurts now doesn't it hurts to
be on the other side that's right that's
the point of this video
Hey the fact that Dre can figure out
fortnight is amazing frankly I would be
amazed if he tied his own shoes
and looky loo he turned on a TV
navigating the menus and using a
controller and everything you go little
buddy good for you okay that's actually
pretty common I love this cuz it really
just shows like why does anyone care the
fact that we drink for a fortnight who
gives you this channel is getting worse
and worse like if you agree
yeah that's right hey mr. trihard sucks
like this video if you read that's right
mr. trihard got you good didn't that yab
a little BAE
this guy is gay no you this was so
boring but I watched it because I love
you that was backhand compliment I have
ever seen in my life actually this is
how I want all my fans to be just as
dedicated as possible okay my god three
ads on a PewDiePie video I thought I'd
never see the day hey it hurts these
comments are the ones that actually
truly hurt Drake isn't a rapper
he's an R&B singer that can rap really
really well he has only made one rap
album I are teetle and that album is not
an album it was a half random mixtape
made in two weeks but when Drake raps
he ain't soft he has made somewhere the
hardest scratch sucks this decade what
are you saying
pathetic you think Drake goes hard
that's like saying poop is funny I can't
even help myself I just have to be the
end of joke that's this is it part of my
DNA my my Swedish cut miss can't allow
anything else I drove past your house
the other day I didn't even mean to I
went the wrong way
why did you tell me this first of all I
have a lot of questions with this number
one why did you think I would see this
comment I clearly gets thousands of them
every single day second of all how do
you know where I live
third of all what do you mean you went
the wrong way and what do you think it
matters to me that you went the wrong
way
what is this common it annoys the hell
out of me to be honest about depression
yes it's all up to you I have a lot of
experience with depression and trust me
if you want to be depressed and sad you
will it's all up to you I definitely
trust experience from anyone that
doesn't know how to spell it experience
and have a markiplier thumb quizzing I
know you mean well but Jesus Christ what
what are you saying
this is what
I've been saying all this time okay my
audience is filled with a bunch of
low-level morons and if you were reading
this comment Markheim over youtube poop
I want you to know that you are a [ __ ]
you're an idiot and I don't like you why
am i so mean for no reason I'm kidding
of course
you're great do your thing I just want
to say I really like post breakdown
pretty pie you manage to become insanely
self-aware and sort of toxic in a funny
way pointing out idiotic [ __ ] online
I also absolute love your low-quality
visual effects good job good job Brad
inside
thanks for keeping the low quality
intentional affects you doing a great
job
you didn't grain he needs to do news as
a weekly serious this is funny it is a
weekly serious we've been doing it for
weeks I'm glad you enjoyed it I don't
know what to say I'm glad and then you
had the comment right underneath it
still better than BBC 92 seven people
thought that was such a good comment
that they would thumb it up good job
everybody you're part of a group of
intellectual on the Internet
stop hating on for tonight it's not
funny
how about I buy your name he's dumb that
was funny Felix thanks Pierce for
bringing a wave of normal [ __ ] and
children to 4chan we are being raided by
pleb eaters everything is going to and
it looks like there are going to be many
migrations 2hn and whiskey
pathetic absolutely disgusting I made
the video about green text and I clearly
reference reddit and nothing else but
yeah I got so many pathetic comments
like this just being what are you 12
girl to forgot Jesus always knew Puetz
was a fairy
why why why did you come to this
conclusion what made you think this was
confirmed in your head I don't know why
these things are knowing me so much like
why it made you think to come up with
this comment
what was the thought process and why did
six people thumb it I don't understand
you guys I feel like he's trying so hard
to be funny sometimes it's kind of sad
oh how the mighty have fallen
what do you say you even edited this
comment of course I try to be funny
that's the point of my videos that's
what I do every single day if you think
I've been trying to be funny now just
watch my old videos and literally pause
sometimes and go ah let me think of a
joke here yeah I read these comments I'm
like what are you trying to say what
made you come up to this idea this video
is literally like every single other one
of my videos all my videos are the same
you stupid hey I'm hungry I want some
lasagna why do I even read the comments
hate your new videos I love your old
videos just watch the old ones thing you
slimy weasel scum that's right I'm not
afraid to call you guys out for what you
are you stupid
you dumb a dummy scummy dummy bum that's
what you are
and I would smack it without no oil come
all over you I didn't mean that last bit
I meant that the boil would come god
damn it I'm glad that Felix is getting
sponsors again well that's a nice
comment actually that's right despite
two major media breakdance still here
still getting sponsors again yay for me
never thought it would happen gets a six
thousand dollar PC with two 1080 T
Titans and an eight core CPU plays
roblox why are you hating on roblox now
damn game on the market for the most
advanced graphics that has ever existed
pathetic
you guys who'd like to complain about
everything don't you you just April
fooled everyone this video was published
March 30th this is the thing that
happens all the time with comments just
because you watched it during April
Fool's does it doesn't mean it was
published it's the same thing when I did
Fridays with PewDiePie back in the day
and people would watch it on the Sunday
and they black
watching in the Friday lepakqueen he is
trigger law it's triggered it's trig
earned with a day and no I'm not I was
thinking why so low FPS here's
millionaire that's right everyone the
more money you have them the bedroom the
more frame rates that's just a scale
that works for everyone I was reacting
to videos [ __ ] it's not my gameplay
Thank You Edgar yo boots just ruined
YouTube he always tries to like act
funny but he's weird just yeah I
appreciate the effort but not the result
I'm not doing this to get attention yes
you are and you did have you heard of
comics have you heard of sentence
building no I don't think so huh yes you
push the ass
you guys are just freaking freaks I
don't appreciate these comments you are
clearly doing it for attention
what do you mean I ruins YouTube it's
called ruined dummy hahahahaha there
hear this ha I'm watching this on Sunday
no one cares no one cares I don't care
when you're watching it it's none of my
concern
I'll put it on the right day so annoying
I had a dream about you last night Felix
quite magical I met you I asked if you
could drive me home it took five minutes
you did and I said thanks and left it
was truly magnificent thanks buttes
keep me out of your weird fetish
fantasies please I don't need to hear
about this what the heck what 646 405
703 724 good job Brad what does this
mean the big Campbell great good job
good job Brad what do we have here
another reload that's right everybody
all my videos are just we helped loads
of reuploads and reuploads
there's no original content anymore I'm
just reading the video I did now eight
years ago that's right I made this video
eight years ago you're welcome
what's that in the right bottom corner
at 5:49 549
all right
for real though I'd really enjoyed
reading the comments to something that
I've always really really enjoyed I I
think the day I stopped reading the
comments is probably the day that I
should end YouTube because the
interaction that I get between you guys
is what I enjoy the most
I know it's like a mean that I steal
your Condor or whatever but I to me it's
more like we have a community and I'm
just justifying stealing but with the
comments I I genuinely enjoyed it and
seeing when you guys laugh at stuff that
you thought were funny or leaving a nice
comment or bad I still really enjoy
reading it and I enjoy especially
laughing at these dumb ones I definitely
noticed a huge shift from the last six
months
way more positive comments people are it
seem like you guys are really enjoying
the videos and I'm having a blast making
them I think for the first time like I
finally actually figured out how to make
videos because I have weekly series and
I just makes my life so much easier and
so much more enjoyable I know it's like
a mean that I'm just stealing content
but if that's the case I'll take it
because I'm having a blast and it seems
like you guys are enjoying it well so
keep up the great work everybody that
being said I am actually going away I'm
going to travel so I don't know if there
will be some weird gap in between the
videos hopefully not but that's just my
announcement saying that that being said
I'll see you guys next time I'm just I
don't know when I'll be back I don't
know anything but I will be back at some
point in the future so I see you good
bye good bye